- Your daughter is almost 16.
- Yes.
- What's she like?
We have a 3, 5, 13, and 18-year-old, so.
- I mean, you lost me
after the second one.
- Yeah, well, no, but a teenager,
that can be trying.
- Oh, my God, just keep
us in your prayers.
(Kelly laughs)
My daughter,
it's hard to watch yourself,
she's like, watching
now, that she's older,
it's like watching myself, it's scary.
What I'm so grateful to God
for is that I am a woman,
And I can teach her how to be a woman.
(audience cheers)
Had I had a male child,
it would've been a little different.
- Yeah.
- I was a single mom,
which I did not expect to be.
I didn't have her until
I was 35 years old,
so had already had career
first and then kind of,
you know, just got into motherhood
and I think it's been the most gratifying
and amazing, and just rocky road
that I've ever taken in my life,
but she's that one person that I would die
in a blink of an eye for.
So it's motherhood first
and then everything else.
- Yeah, there's so much love.
(audience clapping)
And then, sometimes, there's
so much dislike (laughs).
There's so much love but yeah,
- Oh, my god.
- Sometimes I'm like,
- And you got four of them.
- I love you, but I
don't like you right now,
so for your safety, you
should leave my presence.
- That's because they
didn't know us before
we were moms, I keep telling her,
I was like, "Yo, I used to be somebody
"before I was your mother,
"and you might be meeting
this person real soon."
(audience laughing)
- And you?
- Do you wannna meet that person?
- All right, take it
easy, take it easy there.
- And it's like, "And
apologize for what you did
to my body, that's all I want".
- It's stupid, I give it up to mothers,
God bless you, I think it's wonderful.
- I love being a mother, I
never thought I'd be one.
My mom is still like, "Oh,
my God, you have children
"and a husband".
But Tichina, you've got a
way, this is my favorite thing
ever heard with parenting.
You've got a way with your
daughter to kind of punish her,
and it deals with a cellphone.
- Oh, most definitely,
we live in a day and age
where we all have cellphones, you know,
we are attached to our devices,
and I tried taking the
cellphone away from her,
which, you know, it
wasn't really advantageous
for me, because she takes Uber sometimes,
we need the cellphone.
So okay, I'm gonna get you a flip phone.
(audience laughs)
I got her a flip phone.
And now, everything goes through my phone,
you know, so I know how to shut her down
when I need to.
There's a way of
punishing someone without,
you know, not having contact with them.
We can still have contact,
but I had to give her
a flip phone, because it's
all the control I have.
- You know, when she's with her friends,
and she pulls out her
Ferris Bueller phone.
- Yeah, oh yeah, take
it back to the old days,
that's when mommy had a flip phone,
you can have a flip phone too.
- (Kelly laughs) Give her a beeper.
I love you, oh, my God.